on one hand it did shock me because I'm
like you have so much money this would
be an easy pay but then I realized oh
his lawyers probably said if you pay for
it it means you're like admitting guilt
right yeah th% and you still didn't I
would be like even if legally it's a bad
thing to do humanly I freaking need to
well if if that was his lawyer's advice
like look there's there's smart lawyers
and there's dumb [__]
lawyers sometimes a smart lawyer is
going to look at a situation and look at
it holistically and not just be blinded
by the law cuz if it cuz that was
terrible advice if the lawyer was like
because there's also public perception
to think about EXA not only like the on
the paper so like if he would have just
taken care of Jeff none of this would
have happened it wouldn't have
snowballed as much as it did